Today we're going to take our YouTube diamond play button and see if we can use it to cast a solid candy play button in
as clear of candy as we can get
Not long ago
We made this diamond play button mold and we've been trying to think of the best things that we can cast in it and one
Of the ideas we came up with is to try and make the whole thing look like a diamond rather than just the one triangle
In the center, and so we thought maybe we can cast that in hard candy
We've done some cool hard candy stuff before we've made pokeballs with Pokemon in them
we've made an Iron Man helmet and we think now it's time to see if we can make a candy diamond to play button the
Idea here is pretty simple
We're gonna whip up a big old batch of our candy recipe
see if we can tinker with it a little bit to make sure it stays a nice clear color and then cast it in our
diamond play button mold
We're going to be using a slightly different
Recipe than we've used for candy in the past before our recipe consisted of sugar corn syrup and water
But there is a downside to that and it's that if you don't add any food coloring
It usually ends up turning a little bit yellow today
We're using a different recipe that doesn't have quite as much of that problem
It uses Splenda sugar and corn syrup with no water
The recipe is 2/3 cup Splenda 1/3 cup sugar and 1 cup corn syrup
We're gonna do a double batch here. So single batch is 2/3 cups
We're going to do 4 thirds cups single batch is 1/3 cup, but because we're doing a double recipe 2/3 cups
And now we need 2 cups of corn syrup
Well, there are more bubbles than I was expecting and it's yellower than I was hoping for but we're just going to pour it into
The mold anyway and see how it turns out
All right, let's take a look at what we've got so far
I thought that I was making enough of this recipe that I could fill the mold about halfway
And then I also thought that the recipe I had would turn out quite a bit more clear than this
and that I could just let it sit for a bit and end up with fewer bubbles and I was wrong on all three of
Those points and this is after doing a fair bit of research on how to make this work
So clearly I need to do some more research and we'll try something else again
Her sugar layer seems to have hardened quite a bit
So we'll see if we can pop it out in what sort of texture we have. I'm guessing one with a lot of bubbles
We've got the shape really well as
You can probably see though. The surface is just completely covered in bubbles like everywhere
I do still think it's gonna be possible to get this whole thing as one solid clear block of sugar
I may need to use a different type of artificial sugar. There's something called isomalt that I know is often used for this
So I might have tried getting my hands on that
All right
Well, apparently I am terrible making things out of isomalt because this was supposed to be clear and instead
It's well completely opaque more than any isomalt has ever been opaque ever. So I need to call in an expert Cali
Yeah, okay. I
I'm not good at ice and well
Actually, it doesn't even taste good I've worked with ice melt a lot so I have made it clear many many times
I didn't actually know it could do this
not either it's a lot simpler than people make it out to be I really come down to
Clean tools and exactly what ingredients ice melt if you want it clear
You're not worrying about adding food coloring or flavoring or anything else?
You just need the ice mold itself and then you just need to make sure you keep everything clean. It's about easy
So I will clarify add one things even
Instructions on the backs of these will sometimes tell you to add a couple tablespoons of water to about a cup of ice and melt
And melt that down
You can
Especially if you're adding food coloring, you'll still get a pretty decent result
But it's still gonna turn out a little bit cloudy or it won't be perfectly clear
You're gonna get a yellowish tinge with tap water
Now if you use distilled water, you'll have better results
but honestly
You can just mop isomalt on its own which is what makes it so unique
Even from sugar from all of the other things that makes it different the clarity of it is the main thing
But the fact that you can just melt it down on its own and you can get beautiful results
It's kind of what makes it so special. Let's try it. All right, I'll show you to
perfectly clean metal pot
this is nonstick and then I've got two new clean spatulas that Nate has never stirred anything or burned anything with
Nice
Turtle medium mm. We're gonna start it 20 minutes medium heat
So once it hits a certain level of heat, I think it's close to the hard crack stage for sugar
It will discolor no matter what there's no saving isomalt
If you burn it, you leave it on a medium heat you don't need to worry about it not dissolving correctly
What's gonna happen is it's gonna melt from the bottom. You can tip it gently
You don't want to stir it because of those bubbles
You don't want to really mess with it too much
All we're gonna use the spatula score is to poke any of the stuff that hasn't fully melted down to the bottom
Once it looks nearly done. We'll turn off the heat 40 minutes. I say we're going to be good to go
So, I mean we can compare do you want to hold this next to your diamond plate
No, let's just pour this in and you can compare my failure to your success. Later
So that's probably gonna take I would say seven hours
I'm probably gonna let it cure at least
so you might as well just leave it overnight and then it should be nice and hard and it should be clear and then we
Take it out, and we just melt those bubbles off. I'll be good to go
There are bubbles and you can definitely see bubble, ooh the top guys we've got a clear piece of candy here
That was a very good sign
Okay, a little bit of discoloration and a lot of bubbles that could be worse and we can actually get rid of these
Guys we learned so much about this namely you can't put sugar in a silicone mold
Mmm, hot sugar bubbles on contact with silicone. That's pretty much unavoidable
We even tried making some other types of molds
But those like I made one out of thermoplastic, but thermoplastic isn't gonna hold up to hot candy being poured in to do it
Just melt again
and so in the end what we did is we did use the diamond play button mold and then we just
Blow torched over the surface to smooth it out
This one is obviously the correct size but gosh the bubbles are bad
So we've just got so much candy here. This one was pretty good except that it's too thin and
We let it solidify all the way and once it's solidified and it's a separate batch
Like you're never gonna get the color just right. It's not gonna laminate perfectly to it
And so we would have a gap there forever. And we really wanted like the right thickness all the way through same color
That one here that ended up being a little bit too dark
You can see it is red if we hold it up to a light
But if you're not holding it up to a light it kind of just looks black and we tried pouring
Another layer of molten sugar over it
Rips here's the pour lines off to the side. It did not get rid of the bubbles
like we hoped it would now the
Isomalt, actually, I think if we hadn't been using a silicone mold would have been our best bet
The problem is Isum all over a long period of time and the fact that we've had it above the stove
So it's been steaming up when opaque again
However, you can see where we took a blowtorch to it
And the nice thing about ice mold is unlike sugar when it heats up it stays
Beautifully clear. It doesn't caramelize at all. Well, I can burn it if you're too hot, but it doesn't caramelize and turn like yellow
Guys thanks for watching
You know
That's not all we've always got more to see the box at the top is gonna take you to our last video
You should go check that out. The other box shows you what YouTube thinks you should be watching next
They've hit this bomb here in the middle
You'll be subscribed to the channel and that way you're never going to miss out on a cool video
Don't forget to ring the bell and we'll see you the next one. Talk to you then